There are a few rules to follow when traversing
through the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
The most important rule is one that's already
been long-established in comic books: death
isn't necessarily final, and some goodbyes
are really just "see you later"s.
"So dead brother huh?"
"Yeah, that could be annoying."
"Well, he's been dead before."
As it turns out, that last rule will apply
to the fourth Avengers movie in a big way.
It's not really a surprise that some dearly-departed
heroes are making their way back to life in
the super-sequel.
But according to one MCU actor, the Infinity
War follow-up will be bringing one villain
back from the dead in a super clever way.
And if he's telling the truth, the details
just might confirm a major fan theory.
Speaking on the UFC Unfiltered podcast, actor
Frank Grillo revealed that Marvel fans can
expect to see him reprise his role as the
Hydra-agent-slash-terrorist Brock Rumlow,
also known as the comic book villain Crossbones.
Now, you might be thinking, "Didn't Crossbones
pretty clearly die by blowing himself up at
the start of Captain America: Civil War?"
Well, yes, he did.
It was kind of a big deal, with his explosive
demise and the collateral damage it caused
setting up the Sokovia Accords that still
affect the movies' universe to this day.
Yeah, there's not really any coming back from
that one.
But it's not like the villain is returning
from the grave - instead, audiences will be
going back to the time before he died.
It turns out, Grillo's Crossbones will actually
pop up in what he described as a flashback
sequence.
One might initially think that Grillo's remarks
were just to keep the rumor mill churning,
like other Avengers actors have done in the
past, but that doesn't seem to be the case.
Grillo made a point to mention that he can
spill as many details as he'd like since he's
not tied to a Marvel contract, and doesn't
expect to work with them again.
It sounds fair to us, though we kind of doubt
that Marvel producers are all that happy about
his decision to spill the beans.
The actor's exact words were,
"I'm allowed to say whatever I want because
I'm never doing another Marvel movie,"
But it's not because he doesn't like the company,
or the franchise.
Apparently, he's just tired of the work it
takes to be a supervillain.
Or, as he sarcastically put it, quote, "I'm
117 years old."
At one point in the period between Civil War
and Infinity War, Grillo sounded certain that
he was done playing Crossbones for good, and
even implied that he had turned down an opportunity
to return to the series.
He shared those thoughts during a January
2017 interview with Collider, discussing his
departures from both The Purge franchise and
the MCU.
In the interview, he said,
"There's nowhere for it to go, unless you're
Captain America or Iron Man.
They were talking about it, but I was like,
'You know what?
I'd just rather not do it.'"
But apparently, something happened behind
the scenes to change the actor's mind.
By September 2017, the actor was hinting at
a return appearance to the series.
During an interview with Forbes, he said,
"There is some [Marvel] news that nobody knows
yet, to do with my character, that's going
to be really interesting and I'm excited about
that."
Almost a year later, in July 2018, Grillo
sparked even more rumors that he'd play a
part in Avengers 4 when he took to Instagram
and shared a collage photo of a Crossbones
action figure with the caption,
"Uhhhhh…… ok.
I guess my life is complete."
Of course, the first two hashtags in his post
referenced Grillo's appearances in the second
and third Captain America movies, but that
half-done third hashtag?
Yeah, that's almost certainly a nod to Avengers
4.
On the surface, Grillo's comments simply confirm
what seems like a very small plot point of
Avengers 4: Crossbones will reappear in a
flashback scene.
But looking at the bigger picture, his remarks
actually seem to validate the longstanding
fan theory that the sequel will see the surviving
heroes from Infinity War travelling back in
time to defeat Thanos.
The theory goes that they'll be using the
unique attributes of the Quantum Realm to
go back into the past and obtain the Infinity
Stones for themselves, effectively reversing
the events of Infinity War before the battle
with Thanos even begins.
This theory first cropped up after fans got
a peek at Avengers 4 set photos that showed
Chris Evans wearing his Captain America costume
from the Battle of New York sequence from
2012's Avengers, and it's been lingering in
fans' minds ever since.
In that sense, Crossbones' reappearance will
be less of a flashback, and more of a do-over.
As with everything out of the super-secretive
Marvel Studios, nothing is a guarantee until
the company comes right out and says it is
- and even then, it's still suspicious.
The only way to know for sure what happens
is to be there when Avengers 4 takes off on
May 3rd, 2019.